en el vídeo pasado vimos un posible
mecanismo de reacción entre estas dos
moléculas este bromuro de hidrógeno y
este al que no y este posible mecanismo
haría que se agregara este halógeno este
bromo a esta cadena la cual en el
proceso se transformaría en dos bromo
pentano o sea un arcano que además tiene
este halógeno ahora durante este proceso
hicimos una suposición ok estábamos por
aquí diciendo que este bromo es muy
electro negativo y a la hora de hacer
este enlace con el hidrógeno atrae
demasiado a los dos electrones que
forman este enlace y esta molécula tiene
una carga negativa del lado del bromo y
una carga positiva del lado del
hidrógeno
entonces si el bromuro de hidrógeno
llegara a chocar de la forma correcta
con este al que no como el hidrógeno
tiene una carga positiva y quiere
quedarse con algún otro electrón que se
encuentre por ahí es bastante probable
que se quede con algún electrón del
doble enlace
los carbonos ahora hay dos electrones
con los que se podría quedar en el vídeo
pasado no dije por qué pero decidí que
el electrón que se iba a ir con el
hidrógeno iba a ser este el del carbono
de la derecha ahora vamos a ver qué
pasaría si el hidrógeno se hubiera
llevado este electrón del carbono de la
izquierda entonces una vez más vamos a
ver todo el proceso tenemos aquí el
bromo que tiene 7 electrones de valencia
y el hidrógeno tiene este electrón nada
más que está compartiendo con el bromo
pero el bromo es súper electro negativo
entonces provoca una carga negativa del
lado del bromo porque se quiere quedar
con el electrón del hidrógeno lo está
abrazando muy fuerte y entonces el
hidrógeno no pasa suficiente tiempo con
el electrón y tiene una carga positiva
así es que está buscando a ver de dónde
saca otro electrón para reemplazar el
electrón que se está quedando el bromo
el hidrógeno se siente atraído por el
doble enlace choca de la forma correcta
con este al que no logra atraer
suficiente a este electrón que está del
lado contrario del enlace doble que en
este caso y logra quedarse con él y en
el mismo momento en el que el hidrógeno
se apodera de este electrón suelta este
electrón que el bromo quería desde hace
tanto tiempo entonces ahora queremos ver
cómo se verían nuestras moléculas
después de esta reacción
entonces tenemos por aquí nuestra cadena
de carbonos pero ahora en lugar de tener
un enlace doble vamos a tener un enlace
simple aunque ya tenemos los hidrógenos
por aquí y este otro hidrógeno y el
resto de la cadena
h2 y h3 y ahora sí vamos a ver qué pasó
con este enlace doble tenemos aquí que
este electrón de este carbono se fue con
este hidrógeno pero este otro electrón
de este carbono que forman parte de este
enlace se queda en este carbono así es
que termina formándose un lazo entre
este carbono y este hidrógeno
pero génova y este electrón es justo
este electrón el bromo lo tenemos por
aquí tiene sus 7 electrones de valencia
originales 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 pero ahora
también tiene el electrón que antes era
del hidrógeno así es que tiene una carga
negativa por otro lado este carbono
tiene un electrón - por lo que tiene una
carga positiva así es que se convirtió
en un kart vocación del que ya hablamos
un poco en el vídeo pasado y este bromo
ahora se volvió un millón bromuro una
unión y entonces nota la diferencia o
sea antes este carbono fue el que perdió
el electrón y por lo tanto el otro
carbono es el que se quedó con el
hidrógeno ahora este carbono fue el que
perdió el electrón y por lo tanto el
otro carbono es el que hace el enlace
con el hidrógeno así es que podemos
tener una muy buena idea de qué va a
pasar a continuación no
o sea todo lo que le pasó a este carbono
ahora le va a pasar a este carbono
entonces pues vamos a ver a ver tenemos
aquí esta cadena de carbonos y tenemos
aquí este kart vocación con carga
positiva y este y jon bromuro con carga
negativa entonces se van a atraer
mutuamente y cuando choquen de la forma
adecuada este carbono de carga positiva
va a arrebatarle este electrón al bromo
sin embargo pues este otro electrón se
va a quedar aquí con el bromo por lo que
se va a formar un enlace entre este
carbono y este bromo entonces tenemos
por aquí la cadena con el resto de la
cadena ch2 ch3 por allí tenemos otro
hidrógeno y otro hidrógeno y el famoso
hidrógeno naranja con su electrón azul
que originalmente era del doble enlace
y este nuevo enlace entre el carbono y
el bromo ok
este es otro posible mecanismo de
reacción en este mecanismo terminamos
con un 2 bromo pentano y con este otro
mecanismo de reacción terminamos con un
1 bromo pentano porque seguimos teniendo
1 2 3 4 5 carbonos pero ahora el bromo
está en el primer carbono cuando aquí el
bromo estaba en el segundo carbono
entonces tenemos que regresar al
principio tenemos estas dos posibles
formas de reacción y las dos en un
inicio suena perfectamente probables
ahora si hiciéramos los experimentos que
bueno yo no los he hecho pero si
hiciéramos los experimentos veríamos que
esta forma de reacción esta forma de
reacción es muchísimo más probable que
pasen ok la cantidad de estas moléculas
que vamos a ver es desproporcionadamente
más grande
y la cantidad de moléculas de este tipo
que vamos a ver no sé precisamente
cuáles son las proporciones pero si
hiciéramos los experimentos obtendríamos
muchísimas más moléculas de estas
entonces volvemos al inicio a tratar de
ver qué es lo que hace que haya más de
estas moléculas que de estas moléculas y
la pregunta es si estos dos caminos
suenan tan razonables los dos porque hay
tantas más moléculas de este tipo que de
este tipo resulta que todo se debe a la
regla de marco único la regla de markoff
micov
de marco único
mar
y hay un par de formas de pensar en la
regla de marco único la verdad es que
cuando marx comunicó la descubrió o
bueno cuando marco único la observó no
estaba 100% seguro de que realmente
estuviera pasando eso ni de por qué
estaba pasando entonces hay muchas
formas de pensar en la regla de marco
único y una de ellas es pensar que los
carbonos que tienen más hidrógenos van a
terminar con más hidrógenos y los
carbonos que tienen más grupos
funcionales van a terminar con más
grupos funcionales y eso es justo lo que
pasó o sea este carbono tiene dos
hidrógenos y terminó con otro hidrógeno
y este otro carbono tiene por aquí un
grupo alquilo y terminó con el bromo o
sea terminó con otro grupo funcional
entonces podría decirse que la regla
dice que cada carbono sigue en la
dirección en la tierra ok los que tienen
más hidro que nos consiguen más
hidrógenos y los que tienen grupos
funcionales consiguen más grupos
funcionales sin embargo pues esto es
simplemente una regla
ok entonces tenemos que encontrarle
sentido y esta regla empieza a tener
sentido como por acá
en ambos caminos de estos mecanismos de
reacción tenemos por aquí un cárabo
catión carpo
aunque de este lado
este es el carb ocasión y de este lado
este de acá es el carbó catión ahora
estos provocaciones son importantes para
la regla de marco único porque esta
regla se trata justo de ellos
la regla de marco único se trata de cual
car vocación es más estable cuál tiene
un menor nivel de energía y resulta que
los carbó cationes son más estables si
están enlazados con moléculas que tienen
más electrones con moléculas que sean
ricas en electrones los carbonos son
mucho más ricos en electrones que los
hidrógenos ok de hecho para estas
cadenas y estos carbó cationes tienen
nombres especiales dependiendo de la
cantidad de carbonos con los que estén
enlazados por ejemplo aquí este kart
vocación está enlazado únicamente con un
solo otro carbono entonces es un kart
vocación primario
y mario mientras que este otro kart
vocación está enlazado con 2 carbonos
entonces es un kart vocación secundario
dario y si tuviéramos por ahí un kart
vocación que estuviera enlazado con
otros tres carbonos entonces tendríamos
un kart vocación terciario y sería el
kart boca tiene más estable de los tres
ahora porque importa tanto todo eso de
qué tan ricos en electrones son las
moléculas que están enlazados con el
carb ocasión pues porque los carbó
cationes tienen una carga positiva y si
están enlazados con otros átomos ricos
en electrones entonces pues tienen más
vecinos que le pueden prestar electrones
hay una mayor nube de electrones girando
alrededor de éste carbó catión que
contrarrestan un poco el desbalance de
esta carga positiva definitivamente no
la elimina la carga positiva
ahí está la falta de ese electrón ahí
sigue pero se distribuye entre todos los
vecinos ok de eso se trata la regla de
marco único de ver cuál es el kart
vocación más estable entre más átomos
más ricos de electrones estén enlazados
al carbón
más estable es el kart vocación y si el
kart vocación es más estable entonces es
más probable que suceda y por lo tanto
eso explica por qué este camino este
mecanismo de reacción sucede muchísimo
más que este otro y porque generalmente
obtenemos un 2 bromo pentano en lugar de
un 1 bromo pentano